I've been in business for 14 years. We
spend tens of millions of dollars per
year in paid advertising. And in this
video, I'm going to share something I've
never shared before, which is that I
have 12 internal hacks that we use
whenever we write any piece of
advertising or copy that goes out to
sell stuff. And I'm going to give you
all of them. So, let's start with number
one. Headlines come first for a reason.
And the reason I have it as the first
one is that it is the first and most
important. So to quote David Oggovy, uh
once you've written your headline, you
spent 80 cents of your advertising
dollar, right? And so that means that
the vast majority of people will only
see the headlines in whatever it is that
you make. And it almost feels unfair
that a headline is just a phrase or one
word or one question, but it is also the
thing that is ultimately going to get
the most people to or have the biggest
lever on whether your advertisements do
well. So, think about it like this
because it's the law of small numbers,
which is if you go from, let's say, a 1%
click-through rate to a 3% click-through
rate, you triple the amount of of people
who are ultimately going to see
everything else that you have. And so,
there's very little things that happen
in the rest of the entire funnel that
have the ability to triple. Sometimes
you get 20% lift, 50% lifts. That'd be a
monster split test. But a banger or
killer headline can absolutely
outperform the control by two, three,
sometimes 5x. Right? That is why it's so
important. And it feels unfair because
it's so short. But the thing is is the
best advertisers, the more they've been
doing it, the more they obsess on the
hook. They obsess on the headline
because they know that's where the
money's at, right? Like if you have a
winning hook for your ad campaigns, you
keep using it to death and you try and
beat it. And so here's the here's some
of the things that I write down, which
is curiosity is king, different is
ideal, and sexy works, and never run an
ad without a headline. Because the thing
is is all ads have headlines. There's
just bad ones and good ones. Because if
you don't write a headline, you do have
a headline. It's just not very good. And
so fundamentally, the headlines serve to
give us a different wrapping paper for
the same offers. And you want this
headline to be so powerful. And I like
this visual. It grabs the reader by the
throat, right? And so bonus points is
how can I know that something's going to
work ahead of time? One of the best ways
to test headlines and hooks is to look
at your organic content or other
people's organic content or other
people's ads. Look at the first 3
seconds visually and verbally. What are
they saying and what's happening in the
background and those are the first
places that I'm going to look in order
to model what headlines apply to me. Now
the the really sexy hack around this is
can I take can I steal like an artist
from a different industry? Can I look at
ads that are working well in the travel
space and use them in business? Can I
look at ads in the weight loss space and
use them in business or whatever space
you're in? And so some thoughts I have
are curiosity, quotes, questions, are
there kind of emotional outcomes or
experiences that I'm describing. One of
my favorite headlines of all time is how
to yay without boo if you biggest
insecurity. Right? I'll say that again.
How to yay, good thing without boo, bad
thing, even if you biggest fear. How to
speak confidently in front of strangers
without ever practicing, even if you're
deathly afraid of speaking in public.
FYI, there are entire books written on
each of these 12 pieces that I'm going
to talk about. I'm trying to give you
the 8020 because at the end of the day,
when you're writing ads, you're not
going to read 12 books before you write
the ad. You're going to have a little
mental checklist that you go over. And
that's the checklist I'm giving you.
Yeah. And so each of these bullets are
kind of like the best like best
converting nuggets that I have on each
of these kind of mini topics. And so
this is like my little cheat sheet. So
whenever I get stuck or I need a new
idea or for a new image or a video or
copy, this is what I use to kind of
remind myself. Number two, say what only
you can say. So if you've done something
remarkable or different, you want to say
it. Proof will always outdo promise. So
the reason at the very beginning of this
video I said we spent tens of millions
of dollars on ads last year between our
portfolio companies. So this isn't like
we don't have an agency. That's actually
us spending money in our actual
companies. Um, so it's not like me
taking credit for all the clients that I
have. Uh, like it's not that. It's like
these are companies that I own that we
spent money on to generate revenue,
right? So, we risk real money behind
these things. Now, if you're the only
triple black belt in your local area,
say so. If you're the only person who's
helped moms over 35 who are vegan
powerlifters, say so. If you're the only
person who like the thing is is that
what you want to do is you want to be
one of a kind. But the beauty is that
you get to control what the pond that
you're one of a kind is. And so the
friendly reminder here is that
competitors can copy your offer, but
they cannot copy your proof. That has to
be earned. And so one of the big
reasons, the big defenses that I believe
exists for people who have done stuff,
which is why you should do stuff, is
that it doesn't matter how many AI
avatars come out, the AI avatar can
never have done something in the real
world. They can lie, but they can never
have done something. And so no one can
take your story or your experiences away
from you. And this is one of the things
that excites me about the future of AI
is that story is still going to be
paramount. Why should I listen to you is
still going to be a question at the top
of everyone's mind. And in a world where
trust is going to get diminished very
rapidly where we're not going to know
what's real and what isn't, verification
of facts is going to be even more
important. So say what only you can say.
Number three, always call out who you're
looking for. and bonus points who you're
not looking for, which is actually even
more powerful than the original call
out. So, because it's one thing to say,
hey, you know, I'm looking for business
owners, but if you say, hey, if you're
below $250,000 a year, you're below
$500,000, you're below a million dollar
a year, hey, this isn't for you. Go
consume my free content. It it
communicates very strongly where you
position yourself in the marketplace.
And so, if you only want to help people
who want to lose a lot of weight, not a
little bit of weight, like there's a big
advantage. You know what's funny? I've
actually never seen anyone in weight
loss do this, but just say like, "Hey,
only for people who are trying to look o
lose over 30 lbs." Here's the crazy
part. There's enough people who are
trying to lose over 30 lbs that you can
say no to the people who have less than
30 lbs to lose. Here's the other great
thing about people who have over 30 lbs
to lose is that you might only need a
couple hundred customers in order to
make your business work. And there's
like a billion people, many billions,
but maybe only a billion that speak your
language. Doesn't matter. Point is is
that most people are afraid of saying no
to customers. But when you say no to
customers, you polarize the customers
who are the right customer to move even
more towards you. What you don't want to
be is vanilla. If you say, "I'm
everything to all people. I accept all
customers." Then it means no one feels
pulled to your marketing because they're
never going to think, "Oh, this is for
me." That is the result that we want to
have happen from our advertising that
someone self- selects. They raise their
hand and be like, "Wow, I feel like this
person's talking to me." And so when you
advertise, you never advertise to the
masses. You advertise to one person. And
so you want to be very clear when you're
writing your copy. Who is that one
person? I want to identify the reader. I
want to identify the viewer or the
listener, right? And you want them to
think, how does he know my secrets?
Well, you can only be that specific if
you're talking about one person. And so
as you go through this, you can go
through different levels of awareness,
which is like at the top level, someone
can be completely unaware. So you have
to hook them with curiosity. At a level
underneath of that, you have to have
someone who might be problem aware. Hey,
do you get up at night to pee more than
two times? Hey, have you ever had
someone cancel a contract before it
comes due? Right? These are problem
aware. Then you have solution aware,
which is like, have you ever tried to
collect using some of these softwares
and it hasn't worked the way it was
supposed to? Have you ever tried a
supplement and it hasn't gotten the
results that you want? That's solution
aware. Right? Underneath of that, you
have product aware. Okay? Have you ever
tried this type of creatine versus this
type? Have you ever tried an ad agency
before that's done meta ads? Right?
These are very, very more aware
customers. And finally, the most aware
customers are people who already know
about you and about your product. And
then you have to make offers to those
people. But at all all the way through
the stack, we want to talk to people as
though we know who they are because you
probably do. And the crazy thing is that
customers, this is the crazy part about
customers. We all you want to lean into
the fact that everyone is selfish.
Everyone thinks they're the center of
their own universe. And when you can say
something that actually affects many,
many people, but you can say it as
though they think that they're alone in
the universe. When you are specific,
that is what creates compelling copy,
specificity. And so if I say, "Hey, are
you overweight?" That's that's trit
marketing. You don't want to use terms
like marketing ease like like like um
marketing speak, marketing lingo, right?
You've read ad copy before and been
like, "Oh, this is ad copy." The way
that you get out of that is by taking
words that people use and breaking them
down into chunks. And so by saying,
"Hey, uh instead of saying, are you
overweight?" It's, do you have trouble
getting upstairs or going on a a walk
for a long period of time without a rash
forming between your legs and sweating
in places you didn't know you could?
When you say that, that's much more
specific. And so, what we want to think
about is what are the moments that
someone's going to experience fatness?
What are the moments someone's going to
experience brokenness? What are the
moments someone's going to experience
frustration in their marriage or their
friendship or loneliness? Like, we talk
about the moments because the moments is
what they remember. No one remembers the
vague words and that's not what gets
them to emote or have an emotion and
then ultimately lowers the actions
threshold so they take the next step.
And so for example, I just had a a cash
episode with a gentleman who does bar
consulting. So he helps bars become more
profitable. Uh like restaurant bars. And
so when I looked at the copy, it looked
generic. It looked like he was just
using marketing lingo rather than
saying, "Hey, when you look behind the
bar, does it look like a bomb went off?"
Right? Does it look like this is a
homeless shelter behind your bar? Right?
The thing is is that you're probably
going to laugh, but the person's
probably like, "Yeah, my bar looks like
that. It's a mess." Right? And the thing
is is that that's a moment when they
walk in or they look behind the counter
and they're like, "What happened?"
That's the moment we want to pinpoint
because they probably had that happen
the last seven days. And if that pain is
is fresh, the likelihood that they then
take that next action is high. So, the
next one is number four. Always have a
reason why. And this is big. So, I like
to use the uh the fraternity party
planner uh perspective, which is that it
doesn't actually matter what reason you
use, but more so that you have a reason
to begin with. And so, this uh the first
point when I started adding this in was
um I think I read one of Keini's things
ages ago uh where we talked about how
when people were cutting other people in
line, if they had a good reason, people
were more likely to let them cut in,
which is basically a persuasion win.
They said, "Hey, can I get in line in
front of you?" And he's like, "Hey, I've
got this paper I've got to turn in. I
need to copy it quickly. And so people
said yes. But later they tested it where
they just said, "Hey, I have to get in
line because my cat is back home." It
has nothing to do with getting in line
or needing urgency around the copy. They
just basically said because insert
random reason. But having a reason in
general for most people makes it better
than no reason at all. And so the word
because is one of the most influential
words in the English language. Use it
because it works. And so if you are
going to use a reason, great. Now, you
get bonus points for a reason if you can
tie it back to urgency or scarcity in
some way, which I'll talk about those
two in more depth later. And so, when
you're giving your reasons why, what I
encourage you to focus on is giving them
the reason why to do the next step. And
just that, right, every line of copy
sells reading the next line of copy. And
then those lines of copy sell the click.
And then the click sells the and then
the the landing page that after comes
from the click, the headline of that
page sells the opt-in. From the opt-in,
it sells showing up to the next thing.
is that we just want to be very clear
about our messaging one step at a time
because someone can't take nine steps.
We want to sell one step and be very
clear about what we want them to do
next. Right? A a confused mind does not
buy and a confused mind certainly does
not click. And so when I say thinking
about this as a fraterning party planner
is what reasons does a fraterning party
planner need in order to plan a party?
Not many at all. The bar for having a
reason to party is quite low. Timmy got
his wisdom teeth out. Kegger, you know,
so John broke up with his girlfriend
kegger. Uh, it's Tuesday, let's drink,
right? And so the idea is that you don't
actually have to have a reason that's
good in your mind. You just need to have
a reason in general. It could be your
birthday. It could have been your
birthday last month. It could be your
wife's birthday. It could be your dog's
birthday, right? It could be the
anniversary of the business. There's
four dates that you can run for a whole
month, right? It's my dad my dog's birth
month this month. And for that reason,
we're running this offer, right? It does
not matter. Now, how do we make it even
more compelling? And this one's nasty.
This may be, if I had a favorite, which
is hard to say because it's like picking
between your kids. Um, which of course
everybody has a favorite child. Um,
kidding. Calm down. Anyways, uh, is
damaging admissions. All right, there is
probably I mean, in my experience,
nothing more powerful than damaging
admissions. Now, what's very interesting
about this is they've done research on
basically the persuasiveness of somebody
who admits their bias upfront. So if you
say, "Hey, I make money from these
videos in the following ways." People,
even though they know that you admit you
have a bias, they are now more likely to
believe you because you said you have a
bias because you've actually been
truthful. And so you want to own your
flaws. And damaging admissions, in my
opinion, are so powerful because they're
actually just rooted in truth. So you
want to always own your flaws. Of course
you have them. Of course, your product
isn't perfect. Say so. And what you'll
sacrifice in promise, you'll gain in
trust. And trust trumps promise. Think
about the promises that you have to give
to a referral. Very little. Why? Because
you are borrowing the trust of the
introduction of the person. So when you
get a referral, you're like, "Yeah, uh,
you helped my friend Sandy, so I'll
buy." You don't need to promise much at
all because they trust you. And so I
would rather always sacrifice promise to
gain trust. And so there's a, you know,
the famous Eminem story of, uh, he
figured out when he was rapping that if
he owned all of his flaws and he said,
"I'm short and I'm white and I'm blah
blah blah blah." Right? He says all
these things about them. The other
person has nothing left to say. He pulls
all the wind out of their sales. He
pulls all the punches because he punches
himself with that. And then they have
nothing left. And so basically, we want
to address all of the concerns they have
upfront in our damaging admissions. And
so what happens is the the the
linguistic power of this is that you
have statement but other statement. And
the statement that comes after the word
but is the part that is the thing you
want them to believe. And so you say
something that is true and believable
and damaging to you so that they can
believe that thing that comes after. But
so let me show you how this works. So,
if I said,
"Hey, these markers smell like but
they write four times longer than other
markers and they don't dry out." You're
going to be like, "Wow, I now believe
that more than if I just said these
markers last four times longer than
other markers before they dry out." If I
said they smell terrible and or but they
do that, it's more persuasive. Now,
watch this. Let's flip it. These markers
write four times longer than others, but
they smell like crap. What am I
emphasizing? I'm actually emphasizing
the fact that they smell bad, not the
fact that they write longer. And so, we
use the first part to gain trust for the
second half of the statement. Viagra
only works for 4 to 6 hours, but you're
going to have the time of your life,
right? And so, it might raise your your
blood pressure, but you're going to have
an amazing night, right? Our websites
are ugly as hell, but they convert,
right? Our systems are incredibly
boring, but they work. Right? If I said
our systems work, but they're incredibly
boring, I'm going to emphasize on the
boring part, not on the fact that they
work. And so, by how you organize your
language around words like but, which
are amplifiers, it allows you to say
damaging admissions in a way that's
compelling. And so, right now, what I
would like you to do is write down all
of the flaws, all the things that people
complain about, the things that you know
you could do better, and claim them.
Because the thing is that the prospect
is already thinking them. But if you can
claim them, instead of them thinking
them, you acknowledge them, gain trust,
and then when you make your statements,
they will believe you more. So if you
want to stand out in a crowded
marketplace, tell the truth. It makes
you more authentic. And if you can do
with humor, you get even more bonus
points. So it's like, listen, our gym
has honestly pretty terrible parking.
Our AC is kind of on and off. I don't
have the best equipment, but our
sessions are more fun than everyone
else's cuz it's all we've got. If I said
that, you now believe me, right? The
thing is is if you saw an ad that said
that, you'd be like, I kind of believe
this guy. He's probably not so bad,
right? He's telling the truth. And I'll
bet you his classes probably are fun.
Now, if I just said, "We have the most
fun sessions." You wouldn't believe me
because anyone can say that. But what
people won't say is the truth. So,
number six,
show don't tell. Now, this one is one of
those ones that you will probably nod
your head on and be like, "Yes, of
course, show don't tell." But the thing
is is when I say show don't tell, I'm
actually talking more about breaking
down the reasoning. So kind of like I
was alluding to earlier, which is
instead of saying get more sales,
describe what the experience of getting
more sales means or what that moment
would look like. Like selling somebody
that you're running out of order forms
because customers are reading their
credit cards to you over the phone too
fast. That is the experience of getting
more sales, right? So you want to note
the descriptions of what's happening and
the emotions they might experience. the
overwhelm of having too many phones ring
and not enough salespeople. That's the
experience of getting advertising that
works. Don't just say get more leads.
Describe the experience of what getting
more leads means. That's what they want
to experience. They want to see their
gym full. They want to know what it's
like to have a line around the corner.
They want to know what it's like where
they actually have to reorganize their
gym so that they can actually make room
for more people at the session. Those
are the good problems that we would
describe, which also, yes, they're
problems. But if we describe the future
problems they would prefer to have than
their current problems, those are
arguably some of the most compelling
things you can include in copy. Because
if you can describe the problems they
haven't thought about yet, then it's
likely that you've experienced them or
help other people experience them, which
then increase the likelihood that they
believe it will happen for them. And so
the big thing here in terms of show
don't tell, obviously from a creative
perspective, you want the videos to
demonstrate it. You want your creative,
your images to demonstrate it, but your
actual copy itself, you want to use more
descriptive language that is specific to
the experience they're going to have.
The moments, and I'm going to repeat
this theme because it's big. What is the
moment that someone's going to
experience that they got more sales?
What does that moment feel like? What
does it look like? When what moment will
they realize that this has actually
occurred? Show me that sales has
occurred. Describe to me that scenario.
That is how you write exceptional copy.
And what's cool about this is if you
want to write unique copy, the way you
describe that moment will always be
unique to you compared to other people.
And so you can always have fresh copy
that sounds different and interesting
because you're not just going to use the
same words everyone uses. Number seven,
tie benefits to
status whenever possible. So, a lot of
people talk about benefits, not
features, which is true, but I like to
take this a step further mentally, which
is a cookbook so fast and easy that all
your friends will wonder how you found
the time to be fit and cook for your
family, right? That would be okay,
that's one level, right, of benefit. But
the idea is what is the like in that
benefit what we tied in is we tied in
their friends. Their friends are going
to give them status because of this
thing which is just a cookbook, right?
So rather than say, "Hey, you're going
to cook meals fast and easy." Sure, that
might be an element of it, right? But so
fast that their friends are going to
wonder how they're doing it is another
level of this. And so whenever we can
tie status, and this is why in the in
the lead's book, I talk about this on
page 140. I talk about the what, who,
when framework. This is where this
becomes incredibly important. And so
what we want to do when we're thinking
about status and the reason that this
framework works so well is that we're
thinking about the who, right?
Obviously, it's them, but who is giving
them the status? Because their status
within different realms. Is it their
family who's giving them status? Is it
their friends? Is it their colleagues or
co-workers? Is it their rivals? Is it
their competitors? Who are they who are
they vanquishing? And so, humans are a
competitive species. We do desire status
because it increases the likelihood that
we're able to procreate and create more
kids and acquire resources, right? And
so, we want to tie all of our benefits
to what it's going to do, what they
ultimately want, which is going to be
status. Now, what's interesting is that
the status that people get is going to
be unique to that person within their
subgroup. So, if I'm going to try to
describe status to a mother, it's going
to be probably from kids that excel and
other parents wonder how they're
parenting, not from getting a
Lamborghini. Right now, if I'm trying to
talk to a hustle bro who's 20 years old,
then probably talking about a
Lamborghini might convert. Now, it might
not convert the type of hustle bro that
I would be looking for, but nonetheless,
it would convert some person who's
interested in that, right? I'm all about
mosy mobiles and having cash cars that
you can buy for seven grand and then not
have to worry about car payment. So, you
can actually rich in your bank account
rather than in other people's eyes. But
point being, if we're writing copy, we
have to meet them where they're at. And
so, the the wording that we think about
this, and also just to give you more
color on this, is that we think past,
present, future. So how am I going to
create status for them with their
spouse, them with their wife today and
in the future and in the past. So now I
have multiple different people who are
giving and awarding status to this
person through the copy we're writing
and different time periods. So it gives
you endless variations and angles to
approach the benefits. All right? And so
you want to think the lines so that you
can or so that your friend's mouths will
drop with envy. Right? That's what we're
trying to describe here. Number eight is
that we want to use urgency and
scarcity. All right? Now, to be clear,
urgency and scarcity, people lock them
together, but they're actually different
things. All right? So, scarcity is a
function of quantity. Urgency is a
function of time. All right? So, that
means that I have an unlimited amount of
widgets that I'm trying to sell, but I'm
only running my promotion until
midnight. It's a it's a function of
time. That's urgency. If I only have a
hundred widgets or I'm only choosing to
sell 100 spots which scarcity you can
choose to have then at that point once a
100 spots maybe that takes a year to
sell or maybe it takes 5 seconds to sell
that line in the sand no matter how many
people want to buy it after that point
cannot buy it. Now you can have both but
fundamentally all we're trying to do is
show that other people want it and that
they have to act quickly. What we're
trying to do is decrease the action
threshold threshold so they take action.
And the key to making urgency and
scarcity work is making it legitimate.
There's actually I don't even know if
there's really much more to it than
actually having it be legitimate.
There's there's really not another
secret. Now, there's different types of
urgency and scarcity which I talk about
in the offers books. So, I have a whole
chapter uh in the offers books. So page
104 for scarcity and then the next
chapter right afterwards I have for
urgency which is uh page 112. And so I
talk about four different types of
urgency and different things that you
can do to include scarcity um in your
offerings whether it's products or
services. But no matter what you just
needed to be real that's all I can tell
you. And the part that people struggle
with is they're like but what if someone
wants to buy after midnight? What if
someone wants to buy when I already said
I have 100 spots? It means you say no.
and you say no so you can maintain the
reputation so that the next time you
have scarcity, guess who the first buyer
is going to be? The one who wasn't able
to buy the last time. So, you're digging
your well before you're thirsty. I would
always prefer to underell my demand so I
always have more later. Otherwise,
you're always going to be looking for
the next kill, the next sale, and you're
going to be putting the scarcity urgency
up, but everyone knows it doesn't matter
because you're not going to sell out.
And that's where you start losing power.
Now, number nine is implied authority.
All right, now this isn't this is a
nasty one in a cool way. So this
actually goes back to number one. So if
you're the only double secret black belt
in the area, say it, right? If you've
transformed over, you know, a thousand
people to black belts, say so. If you're
the only, you know, if you have a pro
alete client and they allow you to say
it, say it. All of these things imply
authority and people listen to and trust
authority figures more. And so that's
how we've helped 5,000 gyms or 6,000
gyms over the last seven years. And so
part of authority is also just
longevity. If you say we've been in
business for 40 years, the likelihood
that you are a legitimate business is
pretty high, right? That's actually a
pretty rare feat. So, if you've been in
business for a while, that's a big
thing. Now, maybe that you and your
co-founders in aggregate have done over
20 years of advertising. Maybe it's four
of you guys have all done five years,
but it sounds better to say in aggregate
we've done over 20 years of advertising.
Right? Now again, the the key here is if
you have something as a hook like as
seen on Oprah's best boot camps or best
boot camp in Vegas or best chiropractor
in Vegas or best whatever is this is why
these tiny little awards matter so much
because you can actually even start a
sales conversation with did you find us
on the Vegas best boot camps list. Now,
you might know that no one even knows
that this list exists. And that's okay
because that list just gives you applied
authority when you actually have the
conversation with a prospect. And so, at
the end of the day, this is where proof
does beat promise. All right? And so,
we're now getting into the believability
of the claim, right? So, this is why
it's further down on here because
someone has to want the thing that
you're offering first. Once they offer
it, then all their their warning bells
are going to go off like, "Why should I
believe this person?" And that's where
you want to have the proof that yes,
they can believe you. And this is why
documenting and substantiating the
things that you have done and the people
that you have helped ultimately makes
you more likely to be persuasive. Right?
If you have a thousand people who have,
you know, you have a thousand
testimonials versus somebody or a thou
imagine you go to a you see you looking
between two restaurants on Yelp, right?
One has a fivestar with three reviews.
That's three. There you go. Three
reviews, right? Or you've got 3,000
reviews. Why not? Let's just stick with
it. All right. But you've got a 4.6.
Which one are you going for? For sure.
No question. You're going to the one
that has 4,000 reviews. Now it's 4,000.
Uh with a 4.6 rating rather than a five,
but that doesn't make sense. This one
has five. This is a 4.6. The proof
demonstrates the implied authority that
obviously these people have been around.
They know what they're doing. They
service a lot of customers. It's social
proof. All right. Now, number 10. Always
have a PS statement. All right. Now, why
do we have a PS statement? So, it's a
power sentence, which is what I like to
think about it. All right. is that power
sentence the the two most red parts of
advertising. Number one, the headline.
Number two, the PS statement. And so, if
you have the two most red lines in all
of your advertising, you better be sure
you're thinking about what you're
writing. And at the very least, have a
PS statement, right? And so, always have
them and make sure that they're strong.
And so, I have a number of different
strategies that I use for PS statements
and I'll tell you probably my top three.
All right? So, number one, in emails, I
prefer to have some sort of sign off
that gets people jazzed. They're very
excited to have I want to reward them
for having read my email. So, this is
where I put jokes in. This is where I
put fun stuff that's light so that every
once in a while when I do want to put a
call to action, I make this PS a call to
action that's strong because I know
everyone's going to read it and click it
because I've train them to click that
link. All right. Now, in an advertising
setting, that PS statement is either
going to be a disclaimer of who this is
not for, which often works really,
really well. Hey, by the way, if you're
just getting started, this isn't for
you. This is only for people doing X, Y,
and Z. Click here. That's very strong as
a PS statement. Another PS statement
that works very well is just recapping
everything in one sentence. We've helped
a thousand people. We're good at making
black belts. If you're serious about
black belts, click here. Boom. Right?
And so, it's like, hey, if you did, if
you just read to the bottom and skip to
the bottom like I do, this is the main
this is the main nuggets, right? Your
main points of persuasion all in one
place. Now, you can also piggyback on
this with a PPS statement and have two
PS statements because guess what? The
only thing that's read uh less than or
sorry, the only thing that's read more
than the normal copy, but less than the
headline and the PS is the PPS. That's
the third most read statement in copy.
So, I would also include something there
too if you need it. Now, number 11. This
one's going to be this one. This is like
it's amazing how effective this is and
also how simple it is. And the only
thing simpler is to not do it. So you
have to have clear CTA. So calls to
action. If you do not tell someone
exactly what to do next, you decrease
the likelihood that they do it. So you
want it to be stupid simple, not you
know what to do. You know, you know, you
have to they don't know, right? And so
if you want X, click the button. And on
the next page, fill your information.
then select a convenient time for you to
come in so that you won't miss. Right?
We want to be very clear about what they
have to do and what's going to happen
next. Right? They're not going to guess.
But here's a really really cool sub
point about this. If you tell someone to
take an option or take a step and then
you tell them what's going to happen
next and then what you said is going to
happen happens. You increase your sad do
correspondence. Meaning you gain
influence over them because what you
said after they followed your
instruction came true. It's the reason
Martha Stewart was such a powerful
influencer compared to other people. She
literally gave people recipes to follow.
And she said, "If you want to bake a
cake, here's the 18 steps for baking a
cake." And when you follow these 18
steps, you get a cake. And then when you
get a cake and the cake the cake tastes
good and then you tied to status because
other people say, "This cake is amazing
and your family loves you for baking
this cake." Guess what happens? She
gains influence over you because the
next time she gives you instructions,
you are more likely to follow them. And
so we can embed this within the process
of persuasion. So we want to basically
make promises, keep promises, make
promises, keep promises, make promises,
keep promises over and over and over
again where they actually take action.
And that's the key part is that they
have to take action on something you
said and what you have to say will
happen happens. That's what makes it.
It's not just saying, "Oh, open loop.
Oh, just make promises." They have to
take action and then your promise gets
fulfilled based on their action. So
outline step one, two, three, and
outline what's going to happen next
because when it does, they'll believe
you the next time you tell them to do
something. And like I believe in this so
much. The reason I called my whole
company acquisition.com was so that the
name of my company was the call to
action. So if someone's like, "Hey, how
do I find out more about
acquisition.com?" I had someone show up
in my building and say, "Hey, how do I
apply to acquisition.com?" And I was
like, number
12. And this is a this is a this is so
good. This is so good. I mean, all of
these are good. This is why I use these.
Like, I've really tried to 8020 this for
you guys. Third grade reading level.
Most copy doesn't convert because people
have to pause to understand it. And the
moment they pause, they stop because it
takes more horsepower than they're
willing to dedicate to it. So we have to
assume that the prospect is in a rush,
doesn't care about what you have, has
below a third grade reading level, and
is distracted. And that's the person we
have to grab by the throat and bring
into our world. This is the $100 million
scaling road map. And what we did was we
broke down the 10 stages of scaling. And
so if you're advertising, whether that
be in emails for outreach or writing
phone scripts or video sales letters or
web pages or making content, all of
these things are messaging that include
copy to get people to do stuff. And so
what we did was we broke down all the
different stages of scaling into these
10 steps, where you get stuck and how to
break through. And it's all absolutely
free. And so if you're a business owner,
you're not sure where you're at, enter
your business information. It's
acquisition.com/roadmap. And then on the
thank you page, if you'd like us to help
you with your marketing, if you'd like
us to help you scale, then I'd love to
have you come out to one of our
workshops. We run them monthly here at
our headquarters in Vegas. So on the
thank you page, you can book a call. But
otherwise, this is absolutely free. You
don't need to attend a call or anything
like that to get this. It's my gift to
you. So go
acquisition.com/roadmap and enjoy the
rest of the video. Sentences that are
too complex or use too big of words.
You're not writing a college paper,
right? You're writing an ad that has
milliseconds to catch someone's
attention. So make the process as
frictionless as possible. So if you want
to make easy copy, you want to make
light copy, the way that you do that is
you look at everything that makes copy
hard to understand, you're writing hard
to understand and remove it. So great
copy, the words fade into the
background. No one's actually thinking
about the words. They're just
understanding what it says and then
ultimately being more likely to be
persuaded by it. So if I have something
that's written at ninth grade reading
level but or third grade reading level,
so many people cannot rate at a n read
at a nth grade reading level. Many
people can read but they can't read at
that level. And so if we want to
automatically disqualify twothirds of
the people who read the copy, keep it at
nth grade. But if you want everyone who
can read to read, then keep it at third
grade. Look at the most popular books in
America. They are purposely written
because the authors know what they're
doing at a level that most people can
understand. So fancy equals friction,
simple equals sales. I put every ad that
I write through free reading level tool
and I continue to edit the copy as if it
is third grade reading level. Now I'll
give you a couple quick tips on this.
All right, so number one is you want
short sentences, small words, big
promises, right? Big proof. You want few
adverbs and better verbs. Meaning
instead of he quickly ran, say he
sprinted. And so we want word concision.
We want to have as few words as possible
to communicate the point, but we want to
keep the words themselves as simple as
possible. Now, if you're like, wait a
second, sprinting versus running fast,
sprinting is a more advanced word. And
this is why writing copy is difficult.
We have to think, is there another word
that people also understand that I don't
have to use two words and I can use one.
Now, at the highest levels, I will never
prioritize concision over simplicity. So
simplicity trumps concision meaning
fewer words. Concision itself is like a
nth grade word. All right. Um which is
using fewer words to say the same thing
as many words. But you probably
understood it better. That's what's
crazy is this stuff actually works. All
right. And so these are 12. But you know
I do like overd delivering. So I'm going
to give you one more bonus. Lucky number
13. All right. So instead of 13 because
that might be uh that might be unlucky.
So we'll put bonus here. I don't believe
in superstition but let's just roll with
it. is whenever possible use humor. All
right? Because uh if you look at the Old
Spice ad, the highest converting ad of
all time to my knowledge um in terms of
it took something was a not a market
leader and make it the made it the the
market share uh you know dominator is it
was funny, right? And the thing is is
that if you can entertain and educate at
the same time, you win, right? Because
entertainment makes something
significantly broader. Education is
what's going to change someone's
behavior. And so we want our ads to both
entertain and educate. entertainment to
go broad, education to go deep. The
education changes the behavior, meaning
that they take the click. That means
that they do what you want them to do.
This is why. Now, if I had to pick one
thing to cut out, it would be humor. All
right? Because the you can make ads that
convert with the other 12. But if you
want the extra sauce, right, tickets to
that thing you've always wanted to go
to, right? If you want that extra
sizzle, then you can add humor in. The
difficulty is how do you make something
funny for everyone? And this is where
testing is so important, right? If you
look at how comedians I'm a big study of
comedy because I really enjoy it. Um how
come comedians make their whole specials
is that they will go to many many clubs
test new material and they might find
when they do a 60-minute set that
there's only eight minutes that people
really liked. They then frontload the
first eight minutes their next set and
then they have 52 minutes of other stuff
and they find two more minutes that
people like and they put it there at the
front for the next one. Now they've got
10 minutes. And that's how they build
their sets until the whole 60 minutes is
hilarious because they've tested it in
North Carolina and New York and Mexico
and internationally. And so they've got
something that just converts. And by
converts it means it gets people to do
what they want them to do, which in the
context of comedy is laughing, right?
And so if we can make something that's
both funny and educational, ultimately
we win. And if you like this, then I
have 13 years of business insights that
I've learned. Uh and I think you'll
absolutely love that video. and